it is one of the best restaurants in
town and they are celebrating 10
delicious years and you can join the
party joining me to tell us more about
honey Salt's 10th anniversary is
executive chef Sterling Buckley welcome
Chef thank you blessing to be here oh
congratulations on 10 years such a fan
of the restaurant and you guys have
quite the celebration coming up yes on
the 25th we're having a celebration at
the restaurant and we're having a big
party to celebrate 10 years I mean it's
a big thing in this town to have a local
restaurant that's been there for 10
years it really is great for tourists
and locals a lot let's talk about one of
the signature dishes at Honey Salt I I
mean I feel like they're all signature
dishes it's so good so what are you
gonna make today we're making my wife's
favorite salad this is uh the owner
Elizabeth blau's favorite salad
and I love Elizabeth and she's got good
taste I can see why this is her favorite
salad and it's a duck coffee salad
actually and this is a pomegranate
vinaigrette I'm just gonna dress the
plate a little bit here just a bowl a
little bit there as we say what kind of
food if you've never been to Honey Salt
well how would you describe the menu
there I call it modern American Comfort
and uh farm to table so we definitely
we'd like to take the whole idea the way
I look at the restaurant is it
definitely feels like you're in
communalism's house yes and there's
pictures of their family around and
everything and you you kind of sit there
and you feel like you're in the you're
in somebody's home so you kind of get
like things that you make at home but
elevated yes and that's exactly what it
feels like to me everything is so fresh
and it does feel like you're in
someone's home but at the same time that
quality is just it's not like my home
where it's like microwaves this is good
we really really hard to make sure this
stuff is great so I put a poached egg in
the middle okay and we're gonna take
some don't come feet
comfy overnight and some fat hence the
name comfy and we're going to put that
around little pomegranate seeds
this is fantastic and you can get this
something as light as salads to
something more hearty like meat which we
have right up here what is this that's
actually our new fall menu so we have
our short rib uh it's uh it's a brace
short rib it's about eight ounces and
then we have a cauliflower puree there's
cardamom vanilla in the cauliflower
puree and there's the the braising Jew
and then it's roasted uh root vegetables
and don't sleep on the dessert the
Brookie right next to it that is my
absolute that is you know that is the
Honey Salt classic the favorite had to
bring it here today so everybody can see
you got to go to Honey Salt and get the
book the protein is everything all right
we you put some pomegranates on some
pine nuts it looks like put some
pomegranates it puts a pine nuts I put
some uh orange suprem on there and I'm
garnishing it with a little garlic
flowers these things are amazing
actually it's like a nice little burst
of garlic right in your mouth and you
can eat that and look at this isn't this
beautiful
celebration on on 25th six to nine how
do people get tickets you can go to
honeysalt.com or they can go to uh
Thunder ticks and get tickets you
definitely want to join them and there's
all sorts of events coming up for
Halloween you've got all sorts of Comedy
brunches coming up so make sure you go
to the website and get more information
thank you Chef thank you for having me